with unemployment at 15% and rising in
the hashtag r.i.p capitalism trending on
twitter libertarian ideals of free minds
and free markets need champions now more
than ever
ad man rory sutherland may seem like an
unlikely defender of capitalism but he's
one of its most persuasive and engaging
he's the vice chairman of the legendary
global advertising agency Ogilvy yet he
calls this Victorian Austrian economist
Ludwig von Mises his hero Sutherland
celebrates not capitalism's ruthless
efficiency and capacity to out produce a
command economy but its ability to
create seemingly trivial products such
as Red Bull and to transform the
disgusting sounding Patagonian toothfish
into the delicious delicacy known as
Chilean seabass fittingly enough
Sutherlands latest book is called
alchemy in it he explains why the real
genius of capitalism isn't maximizing
output but the ways in which creative
destruction fulfills desires we never
knew we had allowing us to become
whatever we want to be he's a critic of
economistic thinking on the right and
the left that reduces all human activity
to mere utility and material
considerations
I spoke with Sutherland who is equally
likely to quote Friedrich Hayek Andy
Warhol where the left-wing social critic
Pierre bored do just a few weeks before
the corona virus pandemic hit ironically
the subsequent lockdown that has
cratered the economy makes his views
more relevant than ever thanks for
talking to reason that was great
pleasure to be all right and you've got
your vape rig ready usually you know let
it go we're very libertarian on that in
what in its purest distillation alchemy
the book is a defense of what you call
magic what is magic to you about markets
and capitalism I think the attempt to
look rational which is I think we ought
to make that distinct from actually
being rational or reasonable or
intelligent but attempts to make things
resemble Newtonian physics when they
don't
has led to a kind of destruction of both
the appreciation of and creation of
magic in human interactions and in
markets so the where I was phrase it is
that the equivalent of the second law of
thermodynamics in economics is probably
Milton Friedman's there's no such thing
as a free lunch and the idea being that
nothing can be created or destroyed
now that's broadly speaking true in
physics I'd argue that in psychology and
indeed most magic rests on psychology
particularly perception in psychology
magic is perfectly possible you can take
exactly the same thing rethink it
changed the frame of reference change
the context and you can make bad things
good one of the pieces of magic that is
produced by capitalism how you talk
about it is red ball yeah they're
ubiquitous drink explain where it comes
from and why you know that rather than
the fact that we were able to out
produce the Soviet Union and you know
the number of shoelaces it's things like
Red Bull is why the free enterprise
system won the Cold War when the taste
was researched by a company which
specializes only in the taste of
carbonated drinks they reported back the
into the worst drink they'd researched
in the entire history of the company
capitalism can actually produce
successes which one no one would have
predicted or designed in advance I mean
this is why I think your understanding
as Hayek and Sean Penn would have done
the extraordinary value of the
entrepreneur in someone who essentially
is you know has some peculiar --day fix
now lot of them fail we all remember
this okay
but every now and then weirdly you can
succeed without knowing why and without
comfortably oh easily being able to post
rationalize why that's surely the really
magical thing no central planning
committee okay would sit down in the
Soviet Union and go well for the next
five-year plan the Politburo have deemed
that it's absolutely essential that we
produce a very very highly priced
slightly revolting tasting drink in a
tiny can
they never understand the fact that
living in a street with graffiti on it
might actively become something of a
badge of honor
rather the source of disgrace at one
point in a in a TEDx talk it right you
you said we can make people wealthier by
helping them choose more widely what do
you mean by that well I think it's not a
very difficult thought experiment to say
that someone of immense material wealth
living on a remote island where only
seven things were for sale couldn't
really deem himself to be that wealthier
person least if he were confined to the
island and by the way I think weirdly
this leads to one of the reasons why
people despite its many benefits are
bizarrely dissatisfied with capitalism
but is it now offers such a wide range
of choice that a large number of our
friends and acquaintances are spending
money on things that we don't understand
and it's fairly easy when by and large
everybody wanted stake and rich people
ate stake frequently and poor people ate
steak infrequently there was a kind of I
think this is mentioned as a book
Bowling Alone or one of those similar
books there was a kind of hunger to
actually to taste and therefore
generally oriT we excused our own
extravagances but regard the
extravagances of others as kind of
horrific it's similar argument I make is
that everybody hates marketing except
when it's aimed at them when it's aimed
at them they're willing participants in
the illusion
so let's you know if the idea is that
creating more choices creates more
wealth you you would have in other
places and you talk about him in the
book as well as embarrass talks Ludwig
von Mises the Austrian born economist
one of the great figures in the Austrian
School of Economics why is Ludwig von
Mises your hero partly as I said out of
self-interest because he seems to be the
only economist who understands the value
of marketing and advertising Peter
Drucker says that there are only two
things that really create value
business marketing and innovation
everything else is a cost now that's a
very very weird if you know you said
that the McKinsey they'd regard that as
pretty much heresy his argument would be
I think okay that there are two ways of
creating new value in the world you
either find out what people want and
work out an ingenious way to make it or
you work out what you can make and work
at work out an ingenious way to make
people want it and to an Austrian
there's no useful discrimination between
those two
you've mentioned Chilean seabass as an
example of this what was Chilean seabass
called
toothfish yeah right and so you know
enterprising I guess you know fisherman
or marketers came up with the idea of
taking the Patagonian toothfish which
nobody would feed to their dog you've
just given the name and kind of the
outside of the fish they've renamed it
the Chilean seabass and suddenly it's
you know it's it's 25 30 bucks a pound
how is that not a how is that not a kind
of grift or a scam that is being run on
the people who first first of all you
could argue that what you were doing
there is not so much creating a positive
by the way sea bass arguably was a
little bit you're removing a massive
negative so if you have a restaurant
where the chef is basically cooking up
mishneh and quality food but the
restaurant has bits of mouth dropping on
the floor and smells slightly of sewage
okay
no one's gonna enjoy the meal however
hard the chef works and that's what you
might call a manufacturing success but a
marketing failure now if you have a
pretty tasty fish but you call it
Patagonian toothfish okay you've done
the same thing if by the way you design
a very good product but you name it
incredibly badly you price it incredibly
badly you or you you're competitive set
is very very badly chosen or you or
people's expectation of it is Mis
handled you've again done the same thing
you've achieved a kind of manufacturing
success but a marketing failure by the
way this isn't all about advertising
it's also about expectation management I
would argue that low-cost airlines for
example Southwest southwestern or or
JetBlue or easyJet in Europe we're very
very clever in that they were quite
explicit about what you didn't get and
therefore they tailed a plausible story
not entirely that the true story I might
add about why you were saving money and
so the idea was you didn't get a meal
you didn't get pre-allocated seating in
fact Southwest night you still don't do
I don't think so now you know that you
don't give me sort of free drinks you
have to pay for checked in luggage there
are a whole bunch of other things and
that made people think ok I get it so
I'm saving money on a bunch of frippery
they were called no-frills Airlines in
many cases which I don't want which is
how I can afford to get to Tallahassee
for $69 instead of 250 to be honest
there were a lot of savings for a lot of
other reasons for example pensions for
the pilots of flight crew but without
that story we wouldn't have had faith in
those airlines
we would if they'd said ok ok with if
they hadn't tried to manage expectation
and said this is going to be a slightly
more austere bus like experience than
you might be used to and they said yeah
we're just as good as British Airways
but we're half the price that would have
been a similar case I think of a
marketing failure and that's because
people would be like where they got the
savings by not tracking the plane I mean
the example I was given ok we're
marketing and psychology and psychologic
diverge from conventional logic will be
a very very simple example is it into a
kind of sailor esque
thought experiment ok if you have two
products one of them's better than the
other by which I mean it has more
ostensible utility and features ok and
you have another product with fewer
features
it's somehow worse on those rational
dimensions and the the ostensively
better product is also cheaper to an
economist that would be the easiest
decision in the world in psychologic not
so fast because the human would be
asking a whole bunch of second-order
questions like if my product were really
if this product we're really better they
charge more for it there's something
here that doesn't make sense I don't
feel quite comfortable with this
therefore I can't make sense of the
choice on offer so weirdly instead of
this being a very easy decision I'm now
confused and I'm probably not gonna buy
either of them I had to ring up Nestle a
little while ago because they introduced
two versions of the virtue Oh coffee
machine the virtue and the virtue Oh
Plus which had automatic opening lid and
both of them were priced at the same I
think 189 pounds or something and I
literally ran off and said that you I
really advise you don't do this I mean
just add 5 pounds to 1 and subtract 5
pounds the other but consumers coming in
and faced with the virtue or the virtue
of plus and not being asked to pay for
you know some amount more for the virtue
air plus well basically instead of going
ok well I'm perfectly happy to buy
either of them therefore obviously by
the virtue of plus instead there'll be
in a complete funk they'll be unable to
make sense of the wider social second
order questions behind the price and
they'll end up walking away with that by
either so in at one point you talked
about the creation of the Sony Walkman
and that the engineers originally who
you know when they were tasked by Sony
to come up with this they came back and
they thought they had done a good thing
by coming back with a machine that not
only allowed people to play a cassette
or now we're going back to the 1980s I
guess or late 70s but you could actually
record on it as well and the reason if
Sony said no the reason was they based
the kind of chassis of the thing on a
thing called I think the Sony torqueman
which was a dictating device used by
journalists
and for whatever reason the addition of
a microphone to the thing only added
sort of cents or a dollar or so to the
overall cost of manufacture so they
thought why wouldn't you double the
functionality for a trivial you know
rounding error increase in price now of
course I have to I have to be clear here
this is an assertion rather than the
proof because we don't know what would
have happened otherwise right but it was
a very very interesting decision which
probably only the chairman of Sony could
have taken to say no even if you have
the recording functionality in the
machine I don't want you to add the
functionality visibly I don't want the
thing to have a record button mm-hmm and
his argument I suppose might come down
to the kind of Swiss Army knife issue
which is if if you want to change
people's behavior it's what Don normally
called an affordance the best doors
aren't those where there's any ambiguity
as to whether you should push or pull
you know they effectively you know if
those things have a kind of pad at arm
height it basically says you push here
because that's all you can do and
therefore it removes any kind of
ambiguity or confusion without even
having to think you push in the same way
on arguably if the machine has had two
functions it might have given people two
reasons to reject it which is well I
don't really need the recording function
and what is this for should I record
concerts is it easy is it a dictation
machine isn't a business device if all
the thing did was you put up in a
pre-recorded cassette or I guess a
pirated cassette but a pre-recorded
cassette and you listen to music while
you were walking flying traveling hey
that was the only thing you could do you
either tried that function and decided
it was good or you rejected it if you
start adding to it's rather like what
they teach you in negotiation skills by
the way which is if you want to say no
give one reason because if you start
adding additional reasons people will
start chipping away at the weakest one
you present yourself generally speaking
in broad you know lower case in old
terms as a libertarian you like the idea
of a choice of individuals deciding what
is
valuable to them and being allowed to
pursue them I've been this way I'm I'm
very wary of anybody especially
economists and this is where I differ
with half half of what you might call
the school of nudge I'm very very wary
of other people deciding what's good for
people because unless you're inside
someone's head
you don't know moreover economists will
tend to define what's good for people in
very very narrowly economic terms I had
a wonderful point I went to a government
discussion on how you encourage young
people to get pensions I simply made the
point that from an evolutionary
psychology point of view there may be
perfectly good reasons why people in
their twenties are not investing heavily
in pensions which is in what you might
call in Darwinian terms they have at
that stage in their life other
priorities to put it bluntly I don't
think anybody pulled by going out for
the evening and talking about their
pension plan and at that stage in your
life a Ford Mustang or a trip to match
you pitch you may improve your
reproductive it that's considerably more
than saving large amounts of money and
so one of the things I think is we've
got to be very wary of these economists
don't understand the wider context in
which people operate it said fair to say
I mean of thinking of Hayek and and of
course who's influenced by Mises on this
you know how you talked about markets as
a discovery process and you you talk
about how you know we discover things
that work but we don't really know why
you know in and the medical parallel is
that aspirin you have to delve into sort
of second or third order complex
reactions to things which are often
highly visceral the most interesting
thing I think on this is that which may
be the entire defense to the whole
Hayekian thing is that because it's not
in our evolutionary interest to have
accurate introspective knowledge or own
motivations okay once you accept that
which is Robert rivers point in books
like the folly of fools or you know once
you accept that point
certainly there's Don Hoffman's point
that there is nothing about evolution
that predisposes humans to have accurate
or objective an accurate or projective
perception of reality okay that in
evolutionary terms we are we know when
you design a chair
nobody regards it as weird that we
design it for the peculiar shape of the
human frame okay otherwise all chairs
would be kind of cubes simply designed
to carry the weight of the person
sitting on them
no chairs I've liked that they're
cushion they have curved backs because
we've evolved back to that shape exactly
the same applies if you're designing for
example a loyalty program a customer
experience or a new product you have to
design it around what is essentially the
the evolved peculiar shape of human
perception and emotional reaction rather
than designing is around objective
qualities like SI units a very simple
example yep it is probably a good idea
to make queues shorter rather than
longer I'm not suggesting that that's a
waste of time
but there are lots and lots of factors
in about queueing which you like that
you mean lining up Theresa yes I have
you're an American now I hope you tell
that Americans used to you simply
because it was in printing you have the
phrase a printed that's right and
Americans have sort of adapted it
through that so there are waiting in
line yeah wait in line can be less and
more frustrating irrespective of the
duration depending on about five or six
other psychological things with apps
like uber or left seeing the car which
may have nothing to do with anything
that that makes it easier to wait that's
90% of the value I mean seriously if you
look at okay if you look at most okay so
you Dyson is worth a billion okay
Nespresso is worth a billion okay I
would say that most companies worth a
billion Quinn okay or more or as much
the product of accidentally stumbling on
a psychological discriminator a magical
source of psychological value with rubra
there are several by the way there's
also the fact that you just get straight
out of the car without having to
all around with bits of paper oh and
that had increased the number I think
we'd still rather rather wait eight
minutes for an uber than wait six
minutes for a cab without a map yeah you
know and so my argument is as with a
placebo effect why are we in denial
about these things why when anybody
writes a Harvard Business Review about
uber has it all got to be about
economies of scale and the tedious kind
of management consultancy blurb rather
than saying this thing's kind of magic
well let's get to that question and
you've you've mentioned it a couple of
times you know capitalism as a system
has done a really great job you know
according to Brookings Institution and
the UN more than half of all people on
the planet now live at middle class or
above standards everybody agrees Bono
you know from u2 agrees this is because
of trade it's because of Commerce it's
because of capitalism inventiveness
invention is above all actually yeah but
that is set free or or is is a lot to
flip and the combinations of different
inventions as well we ought to say so
there'd be no Tesla without the mobile
phone battery and surprise oval so but
capitalism everywhere we look whether
it's in England or the UK or the US or
whatever capitalism is in kind of a bad
odor we now have a you know a surge of
socialism what is what is wrong with
capitalism that it sells everything but
itself first of all because I think that
various people including economists and
management consultants who take the very
tailor is to be Oh capitalism where
tailors meaning I kind of strictly
utilitarian around this idea of
efficiency that in other words the
magical element of it which is to me the
only thing on which you should lean to
defend it I don't think it is
particularly efficient of a necessity
the process of discovery you know
there's a trade-off between explore and
exploit and someone who's doing maximal
exploit isn't doing enough explore
and and by the way I think a large
amount of capitalism has has developed
in what I call and the tech world is to
some extent a willing participant in
this which is that you define something
I call this the doorman fallacy which is
you go to a hotel and a consultant might
do this a technologist might do this you
point out that there's a doorman there
who's costing you X thousand dollars a
year and you define his function as
opening the door you replace him an
automatic door opening mechanism you
declare yourself you know the wonderful
savior of the hotel through having
achieved labor cost savings of you know
thirty thousand dollars a year with your
marvelous automatic door and then it's
like Chester Toni and fence actually
you're getting rid of something without
fully understanding now of course a
doorman plays multiple roles as
recognition for regular guests there's
you know liaison the taxis carrying
luggage opening the door is actually I
mean that Millie as his job description
it's not really what he's there for
and he also provides a measure of
security and I think it's very very easy
to define things in a very kind of
deterministic reductionist way to then
use technology to replace the original
function and I realized that this
attempt to make everything efficient is
in many cases deeply inimical to the
magic of capitalism which is it makes
things just as efficient as we want them
to be and no more if you look at poetry
poetry as inefficient prose music is
inefficient poetry okay it's all more
difficult it's much more effortful but
that's what a meaning comes from and
some extent we derive meaning from the
things that are discretionary the things
that are done that aren't strictly
necessary
and so if you make everything very very
slick and efficient you might create
something which ultimately we don't like
very much what about young people these
days who seem to be the ones who are
most interested in socialism yeah I mean
one thing that pisses me on a bit okay
which I will say as a devotee of
capitalism is if you think about the
typical person in Britain okay they get
up and have a [ __ ] on that toilet which
is provided by private enterprise okay
and they flush the toilet with water
which is provided by private enterprise
and then they clean their teeth with a
private enterprise providing toothbrush
and with some toothpaste which is
provided by private enterprise and
everything they do pretty much okay
until they turn on the television to the
BBC is provided by some form of
competitive capitalism right
although Colgate actually is as close to
an operator UN Security case I think the
highest household penetration of any
brand interesting okay why no one else
can crack man okay but anyway let's pop
that yet if you ask those young people
what they really love they go to the BBC
in the NHS well but let's we can't
really from a kind of from the way you
were talking from an Austrian school
thing we can't really say well they're
wrong we reframe the discussion so they
recognize the error no there's an
important thing there which is I think I
think is also revealing actually of if
you think of something which is actually
a bit socialist okay Netflix is in a
weird way everybody pays the same
regardless of how much they use it okay
now I could get really embittered about
the fact that you're paying the same for
your Netflix as I am but you're watching
much more of it okay
young people logically should dislike
the NHS because it's a massive
redistribution of wealth from the young
to the old extraordinary how if you
think about it I mean if if you only
have to provide NHS treatment for people
under the age of 55
it would be you know fairly really
trivial part of government expenditure
apart from childbirth problem but
there's something people like about
something which is not in touch if you
take Netflix or you take for example
something else which is bizarrely
socialist which would be a gentlemen's
club okay where everybody pays the same
I would argue that there is and if you
could understand this better you could
produce a better form of capitalism by
the way there's something in us which
quite likes cooperative ventures where
not everything is a goddamn transaction
right okay if you map onto that idea of
Charlton Heights that the human is kind
of 80% chimp 20% B I think you start to
understand it and I think there's no I
mean the interesting thing with Netflix
when you think about it okay is that you
could produce a much more capitalistic
Netflix where you paid for each film in
accordance with the production cost of
each each thing and we like Netflix
because it's kind of from each according
to his ability as to each corner these
gentlemen's club we do you think about
it's an extraordinary thing because
everybody pays the same some people use
it very frequently some people use it
only occasionally you know there are
people who get extraordinary value for
money out of clubs and there are people
who do all they're all excrescences of
capitalism right and so how do you how
do you then I mean it's the question how
do you make people understand that
Netflix is pay one price deal well how
does a prime will be another interesting
case okay so there's something there
where you could make capitalism better
if you understood what people want now
one of the interesting things of course
is that I think people like
relationships okay that's one thing that
I think is so capitalism so so economics
tends to look at things as a one-shot
optimization game now you've been a very
simple example I always use the same
taxi firm in my local town I'm sure he
get better prices by phoning around
but I like to have first of all I like
them to think of me as a reasonably
important customer because at some point
in the future I'm going to ask them for
a favor
okay well the same time maybe they need
to ask me for a favor let's say British
Airways they've never done this I
suggested they do then sit British
Airways rang me up and said um look
thing is we're a bit over booked on the
on the bubbles are on the 10:10 flight
this morning okay we're a bit over
booked number 10 10 um you're totally
free to travel on the 10 10 but it would
help us out if you went on the 11:35
okay which would have meant I'd have to
come straight here rather than going to
buy a hotel first and I went yeah okay
11:35 is kind of alright okay yeah okay
that that's cool okay and they offered
me no incentive or inducement I'm simply
doing them a favor
weirdly I will like them more than I did
before provided there's a record of
exchange now this is a really important
distinction I think I don't think
economics distinguishes between
anonymous exchanges which is yeah buying
a newspaper in a you know it in a New
York shop you know which is just a
one-off you're a stranger versus repeat
exchanges and in repeat exchanges
weirdly we seem to like a degree of give
or take and so an example would be you
know the the taxi firm could ring me up
now and say would it be okay if we
turned have been early tomorrow because
there's someone needing to be picked up
from Heathrow and so there we really
helpfully here at Heathrow by 8:30
rather than by 9:00
weirdly I'd be really overjoyed to to
help them out in that now most companies
don't understand this I think economics
hasn't taught them that oddly we like a
form of barter some form of kind of
implicit barter along with our helping
of financial exchange and you know maybe
that's the the bit that's B rather than
chimp I have no real idea about this
what's but I think you could design a
form of capitalism which was
there's a very very big difference
between ten people dealing with the same
person once and one person dealing with
ten different people that is the nature
of transactional capitalism versus
relational capitalism needs to be
understood something we love about the
NHS I think is that there isn't remember
there isn't with Netflix okay there
isn't a direct relationship between
consumption and and and ad purchase
do you worry at all that capitalism in
this I guess is more champagne or than
Hayek and Mises that capitalism shows
the seeds of its own demise by creating
a kind of cultural superstructure that
is incredibly hostile to capitalism and
so it says you know the Patagonian
toothfish is that is the real thing and
like we you know we have people like you
the hidden persuaders who fill us with a
bunch of [ __ ] stories advertising
men people who who miss the thigh what
you know the actual power relations do
you worry that capitalism gives rise to
its own demise I'm not sure that it's I
mean you could argue that of course
competitive advertising seeks in a sense
to foster a kind of dissatisfaction
right what do you have not necessarily
true there and there are laws against
that right and in Europe disparaging
disparity over time you have a very
freedom of speech which guarantees it
right there is an interesting question
which is that the whole thing I mean
there is of course school of advertising
which is there to which is designed to
make you the better appreciate what
already exists and you know there's been
quite funding working you know utilities
generally getting people to appreciate
any electricity that was fantastic I
think a girl in Belgium did something
where they got everybody to spend a
couple of days having to produce a meal
for people with heavily rationed
electricity and it's only when you you
know it's rather like whopper that when
they took away the whopper at Burger
King it's only when you take something
away that you realize
we're missing and so you know there is
some interesting work around that which
which should foster greater appreciation
of things Friedman's argument was that
by mostly removing poverty gradually it
leaves what poverty remains an
incredibly stark relief I mean one
interesting that I was going to mention
is that what we have seen recently which
isn't generally spoken of as a good news
story but I think should be is that
there's an extraordinary range of very
egalitarian products being produced so
if you are I mean we can have a debate
between the the xbox or the ps4 or
shortly to be ps5 okay but it doesn't
matter whether you're a millionaire
football player or a student there is
nothing you can buy that is better than
that there is no game better than red or
dead redemption now if you think about
how weird that is in the context of most
of human history where there is a you
know the iPhone if we all have a debate
about whether it's the iPhone or the
samsung galaxy whatever but nonetheless
the fact that I mean okay you might not
be able to afford it brand new but you
can have today if you're on median
income a phone which two years ago was
the best phone in existence well I know
this Andy Warhol once said you loved
about coca-cola was that the bum on the
corner of the president the United
States can't get a better Coke right all
the cakes are the same and all the cokes
are good and consumer electronics is
bizarrely egalitarian and yet we don't
fully appreciate how amazing it is there
so there is something here which is that
we become very rare this is called the
hedonic treadmill oh yes we become very
very quickly near about some of the
extraordinary things that are produced
well we're going to leave it there
although I look forward to your peloton
style ads for the hedonic treadmill that
might be the next great thing we've been
talking with rory sutherland of Ogilvy
advertising in the UK as well as the
author most recently of alchemy
thanks for trying thank you very much
indeed there's been a pleasure